[inaudible]
joining me today is a national security expert,
the bestselling author of defeating Jihad and a former albeit brief strategists
to president Trump.
Doctor Sebastian Gorka.
Welcome to the Rubin report.
Thanks.
Let me,
David,
I am happy to have you here sir.
First off that voice,
you have a very,
have you ever done any voiceover work at all?
Um,
it's don't tell anybody,
but it's my dream.
What I wrote defeating Jihad.
Um,
I asked about the audio book and I said I'm going to get to do the audio book,
right?
My publicist,
you can do the prologue,
then we'll get a pro.
I was crushed.
So the next book coming out in June,
why we fight?
I'm sorry if you're listening,
Margie,
I'm doing so I,
I really can't believe that.
So first up,
we have already spent a good amount of time talking about star wars,
so I am very impressed.
Your Green Room and not post.
I'd never seen that in the quarry poster before.
Yeah,
on the LP.
So I've impressed that is the original 1977 poster.
I wonder,
do you think,
because we're obviously going to talk a lot about national security and foreign
policy and all that,
do you think any of your thoughts related to foreign policy had anything to do
with Star Wars?
Because I do think at some level,
some of the way I view the world has been shaped by some of the Lore and all
that.
I,
I'm not sure if it's cause and effect,
but,
but absolutely.
In terms of good and evil,
I mean totally.
I mean the first three movies are about good versus evil before they become this
social justice warrior absurdity.
So yeah,
sure.
I mean,
but as much as being the son of people who lived on the Nazi and then communist
dictatorship,
these things kind of flow together.
So star wars and growing up under
the child of people who escaped from dictatorship.
Right.
There you go.
All right,
so you are in California because you were talking to a couple conservative
groups here in California.
People don't believe that conservative groups could exist in California.
But I mentioned to you before,
we just had governor John Casick gun,
he was talking with Arnold Schwarzenegger at some conservative groups here in
California.
So there's,
it seems like something is happening in California.
I don't live here,
but I'd come in and out to do these events or something's happening.
So something clearly is happening.
Um,
the energy,
I felt the,
uh,
the events here,
is like the energy,
I feel it events in Virginia,
um,
or elsewhere,
like Texas.
And there's a commonality.
Whoever you speak to,
they keep mentioning the same things.
They talk about the gas tax,
they talk about sanctuary cities.
They talk about the burden on businesses.
When you,
when you get these things repeated enough times,
you realize something is happening in California.
Who knows where it'll go.
But this,
this isn't the state,
you know,
I used to say,
the People's republic just last forever.
I'm not so sure anymore really.
So do you think this could be something that could happen as soon our next,
our gubernatorial election that's coming up now?
Or do you think this is sort of longterm?
May Be presidential election 2020 or
so.
Use the following with the election of Donald J.
Trump to president.
The political rule book has it been shredded but buried and the Donald Trump
jumped up and down on it.
It's gone.
So,
so any past expectations,
any trend lines are irrelevant.
I mean,
I traveled with the president to,
we flew on Air Force One to Youngstown,
Ohio back in June.
And uh,
this is steel valley,
right?
This is the hub of a blue collar Democrat,
manual laborers.
And we,
we,
we arrived at the stadium and the president was in the back.
I was doing selfies with,
you know,
over the crowd and do love the crowd selfie.
I've seen many.
What is it costing me that they want to sell for?
Yes.
Show why not?
Um,
so I got to engage with these people and I realized that in this stadium about a
20,
25,000 people,
everybody was either a former registered Democrat,
their parents or grandparents were all democrats.
And then what happens when the president,
when when the first lady,
Melania comes out onto the stage,
it erupts.
The building erupts with chance with USA drain the swamp.
And this is Democrat territory.
Now if that can happen in Youngstown,
Youngstown,
Ohio,
who knows what can happen in California.
Yeah.
So I want to talk a little bit about your history and your parents and growing
up there just mentioned,
but as long as we're on the,
on the first part of the Trump portion of this,
let's just keep doing that.
I heard you at the turning point USA a event in December,
give a speech,
which I really thought it was wonderful.
Like you described Trump as the icebreaker and what I've been saying around here
is that I view him as the bull in the China shop.
We wanted a panther to knock over a few things,
but we got the bowl.
And I think that really,
it's really the same analogy that we're using there.
Um,
so can you just show further on that?
So,
um,
do,
United States was covered for at least 30 years in this massive permafrost layer
of ice,
which is political correctness and it had frozen over the media,
education,
politics,
all of it.
To the extent that by the Obama administration,
federal government was telling you who could use which bathroom.
Right?
So just insanity.
Um,
and then along comes a guy who,
the first day I met him in summer of June 15 in his office in Trump tower,
the first thing I knew about this man is he's the Kryptonite of political
correctness.
I mean,
he couldn't care less about what the New York Times or CNN says about a given
issue.
So along comes this man layer vies frozen over the country.
Fam slams into it like an icebreaker and smashes through the ice.
So he breaks a pathway full,
full the nation to,
to open up that see lane.
And,
and my argument to conservative audiences is that this is great.
This is monumental.
It wasn't going to be the path,
the path that could have one.
It had to be the bull,
it had to be the icebreaker.
But if you know your physics of icebreaking,
you can send that,
you know,
thousands of tons worth of shipping that we,
that's tungsten hall rides up on the ice slices through it.
But if you don't have the flotilla behind it that comes up and keeps that
passageway open,
what actually happens in real life?
You send one shipping breaks apart almost instantaneously.
The ice comes around the bow and re knits itself right around the ship and
reseals.
So this is the moment in the conservative movement where we have to get serious
about what does it mean to be a conservative in the 21st century.
What's the role of government,
how does national security look so on and so forth.
Uh,
Donald Trump is the capitalist now we have to do the heavy lifting of ideology
and politics and policy.
Yeah.
Do you think he will years from now when we look back be anything other than the
catalysts?
Like how do you,
how do you consider his ideas compared to traditionally conservative ideas?
Cause just in the last couple of months after signing the Omni bus thing,
and you know,
right now when we're taking,
we're taping this a few days before we're going to share it,
but there's a big mess in Syria.
We're not sure if there's going to be more intervention or not.
He seems to be doing some things that are probably a little more big government
than perhaps you want or,
or certainly than his base seems to want.
So where do you think he fits actually between catalyst and the and the
flotilla?
So first things first,
I hate labels personally.
I think labels is lazy thinking.
Um,
and in the case of Donald Trump then irrelevant and they have,
they have no application.
Uh,
I'll credit monitoring Monica crowd and my friend with this,
the weekend off to the election was David Horwitz is uh,
what was it?
A restoration weekend in Florida,
which was either going to be awake or the potty.
That was,
and Monica gave a great speech in which he said,
look,
everybody misunderstands who this man is.
He was never an ideological candidate because you simply cannot put him in a box
because of what he does,
whether it's his attitude to gay marriage,
whether it's,
it just is what it is,
just a mixture.
He was never an ideological candidate.
He was an attitudinal candidate and she nailed it.
Now what does that mean?
Look at the last 40 years.
This guy is 71 years old.
He's not going to change.
He is who he is.
What has he done for the last 40 years as a professional?
He's been committed to one thing,
excellence,
whether it's a golf course in Scotland,
whether it's a skyscraper in New York,
it's excellence and all he's done is he's taken that concept and try to
translate it into excellence for America once more and that doesn't fit into
neat neo liberal,
Neoucom,
Paleo calm.
It just doesn't fit.
He's about getting stuff done and being the best.
How do you link that to what the general conservative movement is now?
I get,
I get what you're saying about labels and I say it all the time.
The labels now,
especially because of Trump,
the labels are all the brothers at this point,
but the thing I'm struggling to
fully grasp about the Trump thing is how does this connect to,
you know,
when I see you right now,
you have a huge split,
right?
We've got the,
the Trump base and then you've got the never Trumpers and these people are,
that should be kind of lining up.
They can't quite get there.
And how do you connect those things?
Like how do you connect to what you're going to connect you with advertisers.
Yeah,
but the number of Trump was a pathological pathological when,
when bill crystal,
who's all obsequious and oleaginous 2 million in the green room at Fox,
when he tweets out actually tweets out in a choice between the deep state and
president Trump,
I choose the deep state.
They're built.
You don't have a conservative,
you're a subversive,
right?
Get out of the tent,
get out of the 10.
So that's never going to happen.
The broader question of what does conservative mean today?
Um,
we can't answer that because have you seen a good article,
a really good article,
which understands first principles,
founding principles about what Trump ism is or should be?
I haven't.
I've seen a lot of people who think they know what they're talking about,
but who've never met the president.
So I think there's a lot of work to be done,
but it's not going to be done by conservative establishment individuals.
The NRO is not going to tell you who Trump is and the NRO is not going to
revitalize the conservative establishment.
Right.
This is a new era.
It's exciting,
but we have to get to work to define what it means to be a conservative
to me is why it seems so obvious that you're so passionate about this that
nobody else was going to do it.
And I think that's all.
So that's sort of what Monica was saying and it's sorta what Horowitz has been
saying for a long time.
Even when he sat right there that no one else was going to break through,
and now it's imperfect,
but at least there's
let,
let me be brutally candid.
You know,
I grew up in the UK to Hungarian parents who escaped communism.
I went through the,
the private school system in the UK,
stiff upper lip and all that stuff,
and the debating club.
So the president's style is not exactly the style on used to.
I got to get used to it.
And I understand that people have issues.
The biggest people,
the biggest thing people have issues with on,
on the right or his tweets.
I get it.
But guess what?
Who was going to Defeat Hillary?
Wasn't Jeb Bush,
wasn't even Senator Cruz.
None of them are going to the only person who could come through that.
My asthma who could break through the ice or political correctness was this rank
outsider from Manhattan.
And whether you like it or not,
he to say for the softly,
he was the necessary but not sufficient because of victory.
Um,
you don't have to like it,
but it happed to be him with that stock.
We tried to do Marquess of Queensberry rules for 30 years.
Where did it get us?
What did he get us?
Mitt Romney.
Come on guys.
Right?
So it had to be Donald Trump.
Now we have to backfill what it means.
Yeah.
And that seems to be where I think you,
and so many of these other people that are either part or formerly part of the
administration.
So you had a very brief stint at the administration.
Uh,
first of all,
we've done some luck,
right?
I think years from now they'll go,
oh my God,
he was there for 90% longer than everybody else.
But,
but it pretty brief stint seven months.
First,
can you just tell me how you got involved because you had only,
you just mentioned you only met him a little bit before the election in the
first place and then,
and then sort of what happened that had you leave because that will really tie
into the media,
which I think we're very much aligned on what's going on with the media right
now.
So a summer of 15,
I got a phone call from a guy called Cory 11 Gowski that I'd never heard of.
And he said,
uh,
candidate Trump is prepping for the big full GOP presidential debate on national
security.
And he'd like to talk to you
said,
sure.
So I took the plane,
flew to New York,
went to Trump tower.
It was just the three of us in Donald Trump's office.
And we had this incredible blue sky discussion on national security issues.
You name it from the civil war up to the Middle East and nuclear weapons,
all kinds of topics.
How knowledgeable did he seem about things?
Cause this is one of the parts that I think people we have no handle on.
Like does he really passionate and really interested but not a guy that you're
going to debate what happened in Karbala in the ninth century.
But,
but,
but really interested in this stuff and with opinions and,
and halfway through this discussion and he was sitting closer to me than you
are.
And Courtney's over here and he does a classic Trumpism.
He goes,
just stops the conversation.
Cholerae I like this guy,
let's hire him.
And that was it.
And he asked me to help write.
It wasn't part of the campaign,
but I became an advisor,
wrote policy papers that he used and the briefings,
uh,
and we stayed in touch,
but I never joined the campaign.
And then as things progressed and he,
you know,
the field whittled down to what it did,
I kept meeting General Flynn at events.
I was a participant.
I was just in the crowd and I kept bumping into General Flynn and I'd known him
from when he was director of the Dia.
And eventually we just,
he pulled me in and by October,
the month before the election,
I don't know if you're familiar with the system and in,
in,
in the presidential election,
the last two runners get,
uh,
support from the federal government before the election and they get offices
near the White House to create transition teams to prep.
And so Hillary got one story and,
and the president got another store of this building and I was pulled into the
pits.
Hilarious.
It's in the same building.
Oh yeah.
And if you're talking there,
the elevator.
Right.
So,
so I got pulled in and asked to work on the National Security Council Transition
Team for General Flynn.
And my wife,
who has a background in the issues was pulled into work on the DHS team.
And uh,
so I became part of the official transition team.
And up til the very last moment,
the week,
you know,
maybe the week of the inauguration I was going to be doing counter terrorism
stuff.
The General Flynn and the NFC,
and then Steve Bannon,
who knows me,
reaches out in the last minutes of the new,
they're going to come and work for me and the office of the chief strategist,
the strategist to the president.
And that's how you know,
at uh,
1201 on January the 20th,
I became a deputy assistant to the president.
Yeah.
So the second that happened,
basically the media just went bananas.
And I knew,
I mean,
every store I mentioned to you that right?
No,
no,
no.
The act when they went bananas,
was it even before that?
No,
no,
no.
It's very interesting.
They didn't,
they didn't go up honors until the,
the travel ban dropped.
And I realized things were not going well in terms of communicating the travel
ban.
So I said to Steve and I set the shore and guys,
I've done a bit of media in the past.
Uh,
I can be the face of this stuff if you want.
I mean,
we've got the NSC communications team,
but I'm prepared to go on CNN and debate these guys.
And so they threw me into the,
the,
you know,
the fire and I loved it and the left went nuts.
They just absolutely went insane.
And it was once I was vehemently representing the president on television that
out came the hip pieces and the lights.
Yeah.
So let's talk about that a little bit because I see this happening to almost
everyone that I have any degree of respect for.
I see it happen.
I see it.
Right.
It's coming.
It's coming to me now too.
I mean,
I see this to almost anyone that I think is trying to be somewhat honest,
the endless attacks.
I mean,
you know,
there were just endless slew of things that you're an anti-semite and all of
this craziness.
I mean,
at the turning point event that I saw you speak at,
you gave one of the strongest defenses of Israel that I've ever heard,
but they almost take everything and do the complete reverse of that.
What do you make of that tactic specifically where it's literally the reverse of
what the truth is.
It's not just like we're going to take a line and make it seem a little
different.
We're a new sign.
It's absolutely,
uh,
you've got,
you've got a big viewership.
I know your why.
I'm no longer a progressive thing has got,
I don't know how many millions of views and uh,
I'll,
I'll open up a little bit.
Um,
the spot besides of your audience.
I have a reputation for being a scary dude.
I'm being a hot ass.
That's fine.
But after the seven months that I went through in my family went through
every time,
every few weeks,
I have the same emotional response and it probably surprises your others
as a human being.
I want to try and understand how another human being,
who's never met me,
who knows nothing about me or what my family has been through,
can write what they wrote about me will say what they say about me.
It leaves me speechless that you can have such venomous hatred for somebody and
pedals.
So agregious sets of lies and you not only call yourself a journalist,
but you actually think you're a human being.
Um,
I was attacked and that's fine cause I'm a politically commissioned officer of
the president.
I'm a proxy as a proxy for Steve.
I was a proxy for the president.
I understand that.
That's okay.
But Hey,
why don't we debate the policies they never wanted,
never wanted to debate the policies.
It was ad hominem attacks and lives.
And secondly,
it's okay to attack me.
But guess what?
It's not a Kate attack,
my wife.
It's not okay to tag my dead mother's reputation and it's not okay.
Attack my teenage high school age son either.
These people are reprehensible and they're out of control.
David.
And then not learning the doubling downs.
So that's the part that I'm concerned about right now that it's seat.
People always ask me,
I didn't event nervine last night.
And the question I'm getting more and more now is,
is this thing turning around now?
I sense my sense is that there is something brewing against it.
There's something brewing finally,
and I think any of us in this space or a little piece of it,
but to me it's going to get a lot worse before it gets better.
And that,
that's what I'm concerned about.
That you're nodding already.
So I suspect you're going to write under what conditions does something like
that change.
If we rule out violence,
right?
We don't want to have violence.
Okay?
We've,
you know,
the worst war we ever had was our civil war.
Okay?
600,000 Americans killed,
even though they're subtly condoning violence.
[inaudible] CEO of Twitter's condoning it.
Um,
so let,
let,
let's,
let's pray to the good Lord that that's,
that's not where we're going.
What's the other option?
What's the other scenario that they look in the mirror and they stopped,
but why would they,
they reward each other for the lies?
I mean,
look at Time Magazine's latest issue.
It's just a Farago of lines.
It's all opinion pieces,
not journalism.
When they look at the people who they celebrate at the get togethers,
they're not journalists.
I mean,
there's maybe six journalists left in this country that are actually doing
investigative research like Sarah Carter,
right?
Like Molly Hemingway.
When are they going to be recognized by the Washington press corps?
Never.
Because they don't comport with the narrative that we're Nazis.
And the president is a dictator.
This is a man whose grandchildren are orthodox Jews.
Can you wrap your heads around it?
New York,
CNN,
Huffington Post,
buzzfeed.
You'll reprehensible for calling this administration what you call it.
I know the PR.
He doesn't,
not that he doesn't have a racist bone in his body.
He doesn't have a racist molecule in his body.
The stunning thing,
and this is,
this is what,
why.
It was such an honor to work for him.
The stunning thing about Donald Trump is,
and look,
I got a Bible in my pocket.
I can swear on it.
I'll swear on this Bible,
this mine once every two things for all Americans.
He wants you and your family to be safe and he wants you to prosper,
which is what all the prep American president should want,
but you know it's stunning,
David.
He wants out for you whether or not you voted for him or not,
he doesn't care whether you voted for Hillary.
He doesn't care whether you want to be bloody throwing.
He doesn't care whether you stayed at home and ate Doritos.
If you're an American living here legally,
he wants you to be safe from harm,
from gangs,
from terrorism,
and he wants you to prosper like he has prospered.
And the left,
this is the honesty of question.
The left will never ever believed that although it is true and I test it.
So when they put you out there and as you said,
you,
you go there.
No,
no,
no.
That,
that,
that's what it's all about.
Right?
That's what it's all about.
What you just said there.
Um,
w when they put you out there and as you said,
you willfully went out to,
to go for the,
for the ban the Muslim ban when we talked about it on the show.
[inaudible] right.
Okay.
So,
but I'm glad for it to their narrative.
Okay.
So we talked about it a bunch on the show.
I did a bunch of videos.
I tried to be very fair.
I have Muslim friends,
I've had Muslims on the show and ex Muslims and I've had people that are
critical of religion and people that are religious and the whole freaking thing.
Look most of the countries,
the most of the most populous countries of Muslim people were not included on
the band,
the original list,
the original list was Obama by the Obama administration,
all that.
So I tried to talk about it as fairly as possible,
but it seems to be one of those issues.
And then I think this will sort of lead us a little bit into your book as well,
talking about radical Islam and trying to,
you know,
make the distinction between Islam as a set of ideas versus Muslims as people.
And of course you shouldn't be prejudice and all of that.
This seems to be basically the stickiest thing that we have going right now.
Right?
Like quicksand even talk about it.
Yeah.
Uh,
you mean the threat,
the threat of jihadism?
Well,
just trying to,
trying kind of things that,
are they real sneaky,
right,
man.
The quicksand of trying to make the distinction of we have to be able to talk
about ideas and why we have to fight for good ideas and against bad ideas,
but at the same time make sure that we're not being prejudice towards people and
making sure that America remains the open plurals,
pluralistic society that it is.
Look,
the argument in my book,
defeating Jihad is a very soon simple
one.
Um,
we live in the only country ever created on the principle of individual freedom
and,
and granted to us,
not by the government,
but by our creative because we are made in his image that the founding fathers
said,
you are,
you have dignity because you all made in the image of the creator.
No,
because Washington says you have dignity.
And that concept of the individual's dignity and the freedom that it provides is
antithetical to the spectrum of politics that says managed perfectible and
perfection can be created in real.
My first degree was philosophy and theology and I studied,
uh,
at this event here in,
in,
uh,
California.
All politics can be can be all ideological differences can be summarized in just
two camps.
It doesn't matter which country you're in or what era,
two camps,
those that believe truth is objective and not manmade and those who say no man
can define truth and perfection can be created here on earth.
This statement that man defines truth leads to the gas chambers and to the
gulags.
Okay.
Now social justice warriors don't realize that they're walking down the same
path,
but it's the same concept to say I'm going to perfect the world and there will
be justice and equality.
No you won't.
If we are free,
there will never be justice for all and equality for all,
as long as we are free because evil is real.
Evil exists.
Man is fallen and jihadism is just the latest version.
Like my book is a very simple argument.
There's a connective tissue between al Qaeda and Isis and the Nazis of the Third
Reich and the calmness of the Soviet Union.
Yes,
they wash it.
Different things wrong worship than air in rates.
One we should working class and other worship their version of Islam.
But guess what?
The connective tissues,
they're all totalitarians and if you disagree with them,
guess what?
You're going to be enslaved or murdered.
End of story.
And if you,
if you deny that reality,
and I,
I've trained,
I don't know,
six,
7,000 federal offices,
I've trained more than that in the military when the military professional,
an FBI agent understands that his government is telling him what he can or
cannot say about the threat group he supposed to be protecting us from then we
have problems when President Obama says in,
uh,
2011 writes a memo to the chairman of the drug trees and the then attorney
general all characters and training of FBI agents and the u s military must not
mention Islam and especially must not mention the word Jihad.
Well that's like saying we're about to storm the Normandy beaches and guys,
make sure your [inaudible] and your boots are tied up,
but whatever you do,
don't mention the word Nazi cause you could offend a German.
It's a bad SNL skit,
David.
Now it's insanity.
And the fact that we weren't allowed to talk about it truthfully,
that gets people killed.
Political correctness eventually can lead to good people dying.
So that also explains why there's such craziness in Europe right now.
Right?
I mean,
we're going to see,
it seems to me that we're going to consistently see the rise of right or far
right parties,
but it really is just the symptom of not being able to talk about these issues.
Honestly,
let's differentiate between the rise of two different things.
Okay.
So,
um,
we've just had an election in Hungary.
We've seen elections in Italy and elsewhere and we've seen Brexit,
let's don't conflate two issues.
There's the rise of very disturbing,
uh,
groups like y'all bic in Hungary.
They don't really crypto nationalists and,
and feed off a long seat and antisemitic kind of era dentist,
uh,
sentiment in the country.
So these are the true sort of,
they're not all white nationalists,
but the true sort of f they want ethno state and they weren't right.
Like,
well,
it's complicated because as history that this tree and on those better psi,
but they're bigots.
Yeah.
Linda gets okay then that you mustn't conflate that with the Trump phenomena and
things like Brexit,
original,
uh,
causation.
And I don't even use the word populism.
I reject the word populism unless your definition is part of populism is,
uh,
those kinds of politics that the elite to disagrees with that.
That's good.
Definitely feel like I'm pretty sure that's not the standard.
Initially for me,
this isn't populism that Trump winning or Brexit happening.
This is a reassertion of democracy.
I mean,
why,
why did Trump occur?
Because people on the left on the right looked at DC and said,
you know,
I don't know the difference between Sunni and Shia,
but guess what,
it's broken.
I don't know what a federal budget should look like,
but we're,
we're spending like drunken sailors.
So it's the reassertion of accountable politics,
vice faceless bureaucracy or uni party swamp dwellers,
whether they're in DC or whether they're in Brussels.
So for me it should be,
we should welcome it with open arms.
This is a reassertion of accountable government,
but for the left that wants uniformity of thought and bigger government,
it's fascism.
I,
so how does,
how do then does the,
right,
how do you police that?
I know that you don't like that idea of policing and government come in and fix
it,
but how do you make sure that the part that you're worried about doesn't lead to
the good part?
Because I think from the way,
at least from the way I see it,
the left is always led now by its worst part.
So for,
and that's why they purge everybody.
The video that you mentioned that I did on Prager u,
that's what I talked about.
I mean anyone that steps out of group think you get purged and that's why I
think there's such a movement towards libertarianism or classical liberalism or
whatever you want to call it.
So I see what the left's doing on that.
How do you make sure that doesn't happen on the right where the far right that
you are worried about,
you think it's fair estimation to call it the fire,
right?
Yeah.
I don't even like the what would override?
Yeah,
I think it's bogus.
I think those are just,
that's a new label for nationalist or,
or or,
or dentists.
Bigots.
All right.
That's a reader.
They're re wrapping themselves to be solid,
fake to be fit for polite company.
Well I hate to tell you,
I hate to tell on your Wikipedia
page,
you calls you all right,
of course.
Right.
And offset,
you know the the page that doesn't allow the subject to correct.
Right.
When I try and correct the lies,
it's frozen.
Interesting.
Wikipedia you,
I told you right before we started,
but your Wikipedia out of all of the ones that,
cause I usually just glance there,
not for fact,
but just to get a sense of what's going on.
Yours is such a mess.
It's,
I've tried,
I've tried to correct the friends who tried to correct it.
Then they froze it and then forget about it.
Yeah.
So what do you do though to make sure that those two things
don't come?
We get the spine.
So those of us that have a podium,
those that are out there,
those that wish to see the principles we believe in,
in terms of the founding come back and be celebrated in this country.
We have to call them out.
Like we don't believe that you use legislation.
I mean,
hate speech.
Gimme a break.
I mean,
either you're inciting violence,
so you're not,
either you're committing a crime or you're not.
We don't need extra labels and we don't,
it's censorship.
Call them out for what they are.
We need people on the right who say,
you know what?
Here's a racist that,
all right.
Think that's just bigotry.
That's just the KKK wrapped up in a new bow.
Um,
it's up to us.
Yeah.
Do you think that's happening?
That's not gonna do it right?
They're going to use it.
How to use those people to silence the majority.
Do you think that we're not enough?
No,
not enough by,
by far.
Um,
we have,
um,
begun,
but there's a lot of work to do.
Yeah.
Everything that's happening in Europe right now.
And there's definitely a distinction to be made between what's happening in
eastern Europe versus Western Europe and Eastern Europe I think is dealing with
some of their existential crisis.
He's a little bit better perhaps because western Europe still a little behind on
the political correctness stuff that you're talking about.
Does everything that's happening in Europe right now,
does it all come down to immigration,
do you think?
No,
no,
no.
And uh,
immigration,
uh,
was the blue touch paper on the firework?
Um,
no,
it's,
it's the death of representative democracy.
I mean,
I've watched this because I grew up in the UK under Margaret Thatcher.
For me,
Maggie,
the Gipper blessing,
uh,
Saint John Paul,
the second these were my heroes.
Um,
and
I remember riding to school on the bus in the morning in,
in west London,
and the bus driver would be Jamaican.
I'd be with my Indian or Pakistani school body.
I be this Polish guy next to me.
I mean,
it's Super Trojan as part of London.
And as far as,
as far as I was concerned,
these are all Brits.
The guy must have,
might've had the thickest Jamaican accent possible.
My,
my friend Martin's mom cooked the best Indian cars.
But guess what?
We're all British.
Yeah.
Gum.
When Tony Blair came in,
when Clinton came in,
this idea that,
you know,
the West is guilty and words like British are pejorative.
You're a good Jurati.
You're short effort.
That was the death of these countries.
I mean,
why do you think I'm in America?
I'm going to proud American citizen now because they lost the plot.
The things that the gis that fought for the,
the,
the Tommy's fought for
safe spaces.
Really.
You a 19 year olds and being blown up over Berlin and bomber planes and you want
to save space.
This is in the space of 70 years.
I mean,
what's going on in London right now?
This is the line of Churchill.
Yeah,
it's,
it's shocking.
So I saw,
I'm sure you saw this,
but just in the last couple of weeks they said London's crime,
violent crime has now surpassed New York cities for the first time in history.
And then Cindy Kahn,
who's the mayor of baton shot a statement saying you can't carry knives.
I mean,
first off,
people are walking around with Swiss army knives.
A woman that might want to protect herself might want to have a knife in her
pocket.
I mean,
it all,
it seems like a mass mental disorder to me.
But that's what happens.
That is the natural progression when you deny objective truth.
If everything is plastic,
then you will get wrapped around your own act solely in absurdities and effort
for a mer of one of the most powerful cities in the world of financial centers
to say no one should ever have a knife on them and nobody needs a knife.
So every plumber,
every tradesman,
every person working at the fish market is suddenly out of a job.
So the congress sane.
So what does your Britain or Europe in a wider sense have to do to reverse the
tide on some of this stuff?
I mean,
we,
Nigel Farrage,
I dunno.
I mean it's lucky that the saying it crops up in every nation.
Every country deserves the politicians.
They elect.
Don't bitch and Moan.
Get up there,
but I see where I live outside DC.
I mean,
you're the conservatives who's so fed up and they're constantly posting stuff on
Facebook.
What have you done to do something about it?
Have you gone out with leaflets?
Have you given more than $5 to a local candidate?
Have you given up and surrender?
I see this all the time.
But people who say,
well,
greatest nation on earth,
and then they say,
well,
you know,
we're going purple and yeah,
there's so many bureaucrats moved in and what are you gonna do?
What are you going to do?
Yeah.
Would you have said that in 1776,
the founding fathers have said,
what are you going to do know?
Is this just a symptom of the success of the West that we've just become so
successful that you're right,
we kind of sit there and we sit on Twitter and we complain all day,
but we're all talking,
we're not doing anything.
Like it's all talk.
It's not do,
uh,
it's,
it's much more than that.
It's deep.
I mean,
I,
I went to the Jesuits,
I studied philosophy under them.
It was painful,
but I will,
I won't regret a minute of it.
Um,
identity is a function of history and culture and values.
And if,
if you don't study Western civilization and your schools and your colleges,
this is what happens.
If you don't understand why people have dignity,
just that they do.
Oh,
unless that conservatives,
right.
This is where you arrive at.
And,
and you know who's responsible for this.
I don't blame the left David.
I,
this is not the day.
This is not the left a couple ability.
It's ours.
It's the conservatives.
The radicals when they saw Paris in fire in 1968 believed that they could do the
same in America,
that we could have a left wing revolution.
This is what your students for a democratic society believed.
And when Bernadine dohrn and bill as took over the SDS and tried to execute the
Chicago days of rage,
what happened?
Because Americans are not rabble rousing,
uh,
leftists.
It died.
It was a damp squib optical there.
Maoist revolution that,
what was it?
The prairie fire manifesto died instantly.
So what did they decide?
They'd read that Trotsky,
they'd read their letting they even you are Hitler said,
give me that children and I'll own that future.
So these people actually became tenured professors in Chicago.
They became high school teachers.
And what did we do on the right?
We let them,
people who are avowedly believe America is evil.
We're allowed to influence our education system to the point at which they
pretty much owned it.
But with exceptional,
your hills,
Dale and grove city,
they own the education system.
And,
and what was our response?
Homeschooling.
Great.
I mean,
I love the movement,
but you're not going to save [inaudible] that ain't enough.
So,
um,
it's going to be a hard slog.
It's going to be 20,
30 years of saying,
guys,
American means this.
And it's nothing to do with your skin color.
It's nothing to do with your sexual preference,
your social class,
your agenda.
America is eternal values.
And that's what's going to be a lot of work.